front of
the second pyramid
allegedly the cafe pyramid it's not
let's see i'm gonna let people funnel in
here
let's see
i don't know how the service is
let's see here it doesn't show anyone's
in here so we'll give it another moment
but right now i'm just going to take you
guys on a tour
let's see here
let me show you what i'm seeing that's
the great pyramid of giza egypt
and this is the second pyramid allegedly
the pyramid of coffray
isn't
there's a camel
this big sucker yeah vehicle
wow
this place is something else
i'm gonna let more people funnel it in
here
but let me show you guys real quick some
of the amazing things on the plateau
that you've never seen or heard of
before or at least most people haven't
this is the so-called mortuary temple
and these blocks are absolutely huge and
this is
at the top of the causeway between
the second pyramid
and the sphinx
so let me show you guys here just how
freaking big these stones are it's
unreal
[Music]
hello
okay guys bear with me here
these are all cut blocks from limestone
the size like this just doesn't do it
justice whatsoever these things are so
big so let me just show you guys
watch this
let me give you an example like this
isn't
doesn't do any of it justice
but to show you like so i'm five foot
ten i've said this in a million videos
178 centimeters
and you can see like i'm barely
not even as tall as it
and hold on here we flip this camera
back around
hi everybody looks like we got 300
something people people tuning in
so let me just i don't even know where
to begin guys so first of all
all of this flooring
is polygonal stone blocks that are cut
and pieced together like a puzzle
oh what's up history with kaylee
um
look at all this
oh my god
so just put in perspective like there's
my foot
and they're all pieced together
and then hi mo how are you say hello for
the camera
you're live
this is motada
taha right
and i'm live on youtube
doing a quick little tour here
so let me show you look how freaking big
these stones are i can tell looking
through the camera here that it's not
doing it any justice
but let me go like this let me hold on
bear with me people
look at this
hold on
doesn't do it justice
i think i'm getting some burnt out here
but
no worries
so let me just show you i don't want to
wander off too far
and there is the sphinx
look at this random
rose granite blocks just strong about i
mean look at this place
this is rose granite that came from
aswan 500 miles away look at this like
it doesn't do it justice like look at
all this
oh my god
so that's my goal guys i want to just
show you
around the plateau because many people
will never have the opportunity to
travel here and there's just so much to
see
that you're not aware of
look at this look at these stone blocks
these are all cut and moved into place
unreal
and again there's the sphinx the top of
the sphinx's head
down there if you can see that
and this is the causeway i'm walking on
it right now look how eroded this thing
is
this was once an excellent shape
and so between here
and the sphinx is the osiris shaft
let me see here guys
there's the third pyramid the pyramid of
mankari it's not his pyramid either
second pyramid
and the great pyramid this horse hello
hi
oh no thank you
no thank you i appreciate it
no no no not for anything
i will not ride a horse or a camel out
here
i'm a big animal lover and yes i've
ridden horses before
but those horses wanted to be ridden out
here these poor animals are slaves
they're out here all day long
and
i just feel so bad for them
oh thank you so much kira thank you for
streaming thank you thank you so much
for the super chat anyone who has any
questions or
comments
i appreciate it through the super chat
um
oh my god so yeah this is all the
causeway look how eroded this is
i mean it's all at one point this was
flush and perfect
and now
this is what's left of it and i hope you
guys can see that straight down there is
the sphinx top of the sphinx's head
let's see i don't want to wander too far
you guys got to keep in mind we have
actual bodyguards out here the uh
tourism police or excuse me it is
required law through the uh
from egypt that all tours are
accompanied by what's called the tourism
police and you have these guys with
suits and machine guns
that follow us around everywhere um i
mean egypt's safe but
the last thing they want is for anything
bad to happen and
let's see here hi history with kaylee i
wanna yeah i wanna ride a camel too i
would love to do it but i just won't do
it out here these animals they're in the
sun all day long they're they're just
abused and camels don't like us
campbells want to be left alone they're
not friendly like horses
um
hello
good how are you and not to mention
these horses are small too they're like
more like ponies no thank you
yes
um anyways i'll i'll get off my little
soap box about that but
um i mean it would be so much fun to
ride a horse around here but i'm just
not gonna do it um so let's see
i'm totally away from the rest of the
group hello
let me just show you guys
what it looks like out here
thank you so much joel just give me a sh
just give you a shout out love your
channel joel wagner thank you joel
oh my gosh this is amazing
hi everybody
um so let me just keep like guys there's
so much random crap
and by crap i don't mean that with any
disrespect but i'm like what is all this
stuff these are all cut stone blocks
they're just strewn about
this is the so-called mortuary temple
a lot of people aren't familiar with it
it's something i wasn't really familiar
with i came out here what do we have
here thank you so much
hello streaming from germany thank you
so much
i would say someone said don't get lost
no i know where i'm at i've been out
here before but all right this is what
i'm talking about all of these are
polygonal stones
that are making up the
foundation i mean look at this
just to show you guys like the size
comparison there's my boot
they're all interlocked and this is
what's left of it they're all heavily
eroded
unreal
let's see what we got here who just left
me a super chat
88 88 by devil blues what super powers
does the energy of the pyramids inspire
you to have
that's a good question
intuition perhaps
so look at this what am i looking at
here
stand on here and see if i don't fall
down
[Music]
oh thank you saeed i appreciate it
pretty horses
say hi is your horse friendly hi there
oh you're sweet
oh you're so sweet look at her is it the
she
she what's her name
oh i love it let me watch this
hi there
and thank you saeed i just want a pet i
don't want to ride i just want to love
no problem yeah
are you sweet
what's that i think
yeah
i appreciate it you have a good day sir
thank you yes
how fun
see like i was saying i just want to
love these horses how many people we got
in here
700 hi everybody
so right now it's like noon here in giza
and let me show you what i'm looking at
i'm walking back towards hold on forgive
me
stupid there we go walking back towards
the second pyramid
look at this thing unbelievably huge
hello and they're laughing at me hi
there
it's so funny they're like there's a
stupid idiot filming that's why the
locals are always giving me weird looks
when i'm out here filming
i'm like it's not like it's so uncommon
to come out here and film but
whatever um
so now i need to show you guys
just how freaking let me look
compare the size of these blocks to
people
that
is how you see just how effing big this
thing is look at this gentleman i don't
know who he is but he looks to be
probably about six feet tall
and compared to that
hi there
you're on youtube say hello to all my
friends
yeah you're live right now
we're live oh my gosh yeah you are
follow me
it's called bright insight
uh i'm from arizona united states
jimmy
a bright insight
two words bright insight
you guys are sweet
i'm where does uh where'd everyone go mo
this way
okay
oh my god look at this so let me i hope
you guys can see it like i am
just showing this gentleman look how big
these blocks are
unreal hi there
say hello
oh my gosh
hi there
oh my god guys every time i come here i
just can't believe it so to put this in
pro perspective
here i am again
i'm five foot
or excuse me 510 or 178 centimeters
and those people are totally
they're looking at my youtube right now
i think they're watching it right now
look this is funny
are you guys watching yourselves
oh you're sweet
oh thank you're beautiful thank you guys
much love
oh no no you guys are wonderful
um
jenny's making friends out here how many
people we got on here 800 something it's
hard to see the backlight but
all right
oh my god i still just can't get over
this so what you're let me show you guys
something interesting here which is that
this stone is out of the bedrock
so these aren't cut blocks this is cut
bedrock
and then
they build the blocks all around it
this is next level pain in the ass
they could have because this is built on
a mound by the way the bedrock and if
they had just moved it over like 50 feet
or whatever it is the opposite direction
they wouldn't have had to do that
um but also all these
blocks here this rose granite which
again came from 500 miles away made up
the casing stone of this pyramid up i
believe it was something like three
layers or three steps up it was a little
bit not all the way
and at the very top you have what's left
of the casing stones let me let me just
keep walking here
but this is the stuff you guys don't
really know exists or at least not many
people i mean i'm sure there's someone
watching this like i already knew all
this existed but
there's so many other little details
around the plateau well you know because
you see the sphinx you see the pyramids
and you just don't realize that there's
so much else to see oh forgive me
look at all this all cut blocks look at
these suckers huge
100 ton blocks or so
um
heavily weathered
more camels
hi everybody
i'm just winging it i hope you guys like
this
got about a thousand people here
let's see
i don't know where the rest of my group
is i'm like totally alone out here oh
there's mo
let's see
well i mean i wish i don't know if you
guys can appreciate just how crazy this
thing is
wow
i'm such a tourist
i am having a total blast guys
i can't believe that it's my not only my
second time here in egypt
but also within one year i was here last
november in december
i just feel so grateful and blessed
i'm traveling in a place that some
people will never be able to go to
and now i'm here for a second time it's
like just a dream come true
i'm very blessed
and on top of it i got these freaking
awesome stones
hold on here
it's time to really nerd out
look at this look how big this thing is
let me let me show you guys again for
perspective
so i'm again i'm five foot ten
and look at this it's taller than i am
wow
and then let me show you guys oops
oh hold on
got my microphone here forgive me guys
i'm just winging it up my hut mess
but look at that
let me go like this
and that's looking up
block after block
look at these things
so freaking big
all right let me keep showing you guys
let me i don't want to get out of this
person's shot
[Music]
and again that's the great pyramid over
there
so let me show you guys a lot of people
wonder about
the blocks like were they cast were they
concrete and guys let me just tell you
i do believe in
basically stones that have been formed i
saw evidence of it in peru
but when it comes to the pyramids of
giza specifically
these stones were cut and here's how you
know first of all right here
is one of the quarries of for limestone
the granite came from oswan
500 miles south
but
let me just show you guys look at this
there's all kinds of crazy stuff out
here like this torched earth i mean look
at these stones
this is bedrock and it's all
over here you can see
what's left of
the casing stones which again rose
granite
how many people you got over a thousand
people hi everybody
forgive me if i'm not
[Music]
i can't
and this is what's left so these casing
stone
would have
you see just how much stonework is
missing from the pyramids
wow
hello
i feel like people are praying on me
guys you gotta be careful out here in
giza it's very safe but at the same time
the sharks of the world do hang about
and these guys were like totally
following me but maybe they're just
curious
maybe they're just curious
um
wow
let's see
i think my group's down yonder so let me
keep going let me show you guys what i'm
dealing with here
this goes down into
the pyramid
let me show you guys
and you descend
down in there you just go through a
little guard shack charge you a fee and
you go down in there
[Applause]
oh my god
i mean i don't know what else to say
i'm out here like oh my god it's because
it's so amazing oh who'll give me let's
see here
is it natalie marta i don't know if i
said that thanks for the tour i believe
we definitely don't know how this was
built
do you think of the eternal what do you
think of the eternal ramp theory
um i don't know if i know what you mean
by internal ramp when i think of ramp
that's been theorized for how like the
you know brought the stones up there's
some there's some issues with the ramp
theory
which is that it's been calculated that
it would have been like something like a
half mile long or whatever it would have
been it would have consumed more
um stones to make up the pyramid itself
and so the question is all right well
then where are those stones now if they
had used that ramp well it's like well
they would have used the stones for
another pyramid okay but like it at the
end of it you're gonna be you're gonna
need millions something like two million
stone blocks just to do that
um and that's not
so as far as internal ramp theory
i don't really know
but i'm very open what i do know is that
we don't know how they did it and
oh my god look how freaking big this
thing is this uh second pyramid is
equivalent to something like a 43 story
building so you don't realize that like
in any metropolitan area this thing
would completely
fill up the skyline
but here we are like we're literally
on a quarry all right so going back to
the casing stones there's a few issues
here the blocks are all different sizes
they're not like one offs so if if or
not the casing stones i'm talking about
like concrete theory or whatever they're
formed
well if that was the case that all or
many of them would be the same size and
they're not they're all one off they're
all different sizes basically
another issue
is that well there's a quarry right here
and i'm standing on it watch this let me
look how eroded this thing is though
this right here
is a quarry of limestone blocks that
were used in the pyramid oh let's see
ron someone just hooked me up with 50
devil blues
what do you think about dolores cannon's
regressive hypnosis accounts that the
blocks are shaped manually through the
channeling source energy
i mean i don't know man i just i don't
know man i really appreciate the
question though
look at all this so let me show you guys
just how big this is or actually if you
compare to people you see how spread out
and massive this area
but look see this is all cool
so
these blocks were cut
they weren't shaped with uh like
concrete at least not here at giza i
cake uh what was this got another super
chat greetings from finland keep up the
good work i i really appreciate that
so look compare
this work to the size of people and you
then you can appreciate
what it's about and look these old
glyphs i forgot what this is meant to
say yosef ayan explained it to me last
year
but you can see somebody put their
little marker there
after the fact
let's see
and see it all this quarry
i mean look at this look at the size
of this i mean compare people sitting on
the steps
oh that's so big
i can't get over it
man oh man we got 1200 people in here hi
everybody
jimmy from the giza plateau
i don't even know what to say guys i'm
overwhelmed you come out here and the
vibe is so special
and you know that something incredibly
important
and special is happening here on earth a
very long time ago
and now it's gone and it's very
heartbreaking because it's like there's
real mystery about our ancient past
they don't know how the pyramids were
built nothing but theories and guesswork
and it breaks my heart from the
standpoint that
i'm like something special that's
happening here on earth and now it's
gone
and
it's going to happen all again
some type of crab medicalism whether
it's a rock from space
a pole shift
something
um
oh my god
i'm making friends this group is amazing
there's uh 53 or 54 of us
and these people are so wonderful oh by
the way here's the uh the guards
there's these dudes here hello
what you don't see is you got full
auto mp5s underneath those suits watch
this you're not supposed to film them
but you know let me i'm gonna anyways
cause i'm a gangster like that oh yeah
see if we're gonna get the real deal
there
and let's see where this goes
look at this
let me go like that just get a size
comparison
look at this
yeah these guys have scored us
everywhere
yeah look at that see that piece yep
gangster fulato mp5 legit
okay hold on where am i at
look at all this hold on
hi history with kaylee again let's see
are you going back to egypt again since
this tour is cut short for you if so
when march full blown tour in march to
those of you that aren't realizing that
um or i haven't told or haven't seen my
other stuff i'm only here for the first
four days unfortunately
i got a broken leg believe it or not i
got an chip fragment that broke off my
femur
but it doesn't hurt at all i feel fine
it's an issue when i walk upstairs or if
i go to squat
or when i'm putting my shoes on in a
certain direction or angle
um and so i can't risk this thing
locking up i've had five knee surgeries
including two cadaver graphs
and
the last thing i want to do is have to
have another but
so what i'm hoping to do is just
survive it and let the bone absorb in
the body because it's happening before i
know it sounds a little disturbing and
it's a little creepy but uh long story
short i'm in no physical condition to
scrouch down and squat into the pyramids
and other type
crevices
and the last thing i want to do is have
an emergency where the bone loss
is up and i have to have a egypt i'll
pass on that um
so march
so i'll keep you guys posted but
me brian forrester and i'm also but
um
anyway so let me show you guys let me
stop showing you my face and
my back am i live
you guys got
all right he's back all right good you
guys got me
i'm running on data so i did an
international plan for ten dollars a day
and uh let's see comes and goes all
right he's back all right good good good
but this is another reason why you guys
should be traveling to egypt and other
places at this time because so much of
the world isn't
traveling it's quarry
um compared to people you know those the
tops
of this is at least 30 feet up
what up
and then you see all the remains of
these casing stones just blown about
unreal and you can see an example of
modern quarrying
for example right here these are where
stone wedges or excuse me wood wedges
were put in there to break apart the
stone
a lot of people don't realize just how
ransacked
egypt is people have been coming through
here for millennia the ancient greeks
greeks invaded ancient romans invaded
people have been doing stuff here last
several hundred years mr brian forrester
i'm live again here on youtube would you
like sharing some of your thoughts if
you want mine i'd love to yep so
we are at the second pyramid next to the
great pyramid
and jimmy's probably already filmed to
show you that
at the very top there still is some
casing stone that's uh that's there the
rest of it's
down came down and was moved to cairo to
build buildings
after probably after the time of the
roman occupation
and what's quite intriguing is here
you can see
that whoever built the great or these
pyramids had to cut all of this
material away this limestone in order to
flatten the surface
to build the pyramid right here so that
would take a lot of work
and if you go up quite close to it you
can see there are machining marks that
go at about a 45 degree angle this way
which is you know quite a regular
pattern
something very similar that we see a
ball back in lebanon and also
petra in jordan so i think it is
possible that all three of those
locations were constructed by the same
group of builders over the course of
time very different from what we see in
peru in peru we see organic polygonal
construction
whereas here everything is very like
everything in
egypt is very linear so i think they
were different i think the culture in
peru was different than here because
here you have horizontal lines very
straight
vertical lines very straight in peru
it's
it's again very organic and polygonal
kind of construction puffy walls and
knobs all over the place
and that's something we're going to go
to next as we're going to the third
pyramid you know third pyramid that
egyptologist called minkow ray and there
we're going to see protrusions
knob like things
similar to what we see in peru but
actually
not exactly the same uh because the
standard story in peru is that the knobs
were for putting a rope underneath to
lift the stone up to push into place but
most of them don't stick out far enough
to have a rope actually hold it and at
the mencare third pyramid we're going to
see same thing they're big protrusions
but you can't get a rope to stay there
secure to be able to lift up a multi-ton
block to shove it into place so
you know again you know some viewers of
jimmy's of course and mine love the knob
or the nub thing
so we want to show you
is this live oh yeah we want to show you
1200 people oh perfect so we want to
show you live what the nub knob thingies
look like at the
the third pyramid also the great pyramid
completely
was covered the casing stone in tura
limestone which is pure calcium
carbonate that came from
cairo there's a very specific quarry
there that's still in use today
this one's different in that the lower
section
was encased in granite you can see the
granite uh rubble
here part way up and then farther up was
uh the tour tour limestone and then
once we get to the third pyramid then we
can show you what was going on here but
the main thing i wanted to show you
again is the fact that major
terraforming was done
of this area to you know cut the
surfaces away vertically horizontally to
create
a very flat platform in order to
be able to build this massive structure
and make it stable
and the precision and flatness of the
surface here
is much more precise than actually is
used in modern day
building construction they they can have
one corner to another corner in modern
times off by maybe as much as a foot but
here supposedly it's less than an inch
on this footprint which is something
like 12 acres in size
so with that i'll give you back to jimmy
brian that was wonderful thank you so
much
let me uh
let me continue my wandering here
forgive me here let's see
someone just oh thank you so much
ask brian how we got into oz wait i
don't know what you mean caleb history
with kaylee says hi
oh wait wait can i
hi kelly
everyone's subscribed to history with
kaylee she's wonderful oh kaylee great
what are you all right so all of you
first time here john you've been here
before um
what are you so what's your impression
what do you think amazing yeah this is
definitely not done with chisels no no
no no
like i'll you know i don't know how they
do it i've said it before but i'm like
the egyptians didn't say they did it
with bronze sauce nor did they ever find
one and the methods have been tested to
modern times they've been debunked it's
too slow it's not precise in the time
frame in itself so it's either if they
if that's how they did it then
well then you have to say this stuff is
much older but it wasn't and and where's
all the copper anyways like oh well they
would have reused it i'm like okay but
where like why
yeah the only thing the egyptians show
them using copper is to cut wood
um
you know so
yeah so don't get me going on that i'm
going to continue to wander around a bit
here a little kid
and if you look down here
there's the third pyramid
mencare
let's see who it here just said to the
thing oz equals australia oh right on
let's see here
and again the size of it you just don't
realize i mean compared to people see
that gentleman with the yellow shirt
he's six foot nine his name's kyle he's
wonderful but just to put in perspective
so he's a giant six foot nine is huge
and look how small he is compared
unreal
how is that someone says is the weather
hot it's not bad it's about 90 degrees
fahrenheit but there's a nice breeze so
i feel all right i'm definitely getting
burnt i can sense that but um
i just can't believe i'm back out here
and again look at all these granite
blocks just strung about
unreal
and again
what you're seeing here the first few
layers is bedrock these are not they cut
the bedrock into steps and then after
the first few layers up
is when they start stacking the stones
but let me just compare it to the size
of these people
you're good you're not ben you're good
you know you're providing perspective uh
i want to be able to show people the
size of it and it's not until you
compare it to people that you appreciate
just how
freaking enormous this thing is
yeah see again all of this is cut out of
bedrock and then they put everything all
the blocks on top of it
complete pain in the ass construction
and they didn't have to do that but they
chose to for a reason which is another
reason why i think that these
pyramids had actual purpose and were
functional
um
more than just some decorative tomb
but don't get me going on that right now
wow
wow i still can't believe i'm out here
so what i want to do is all right
someone said here let's see can you see
water erosion on the bedrock there
um over where i was at the beginning of
this
on the causeway it's heavily eroded
um i'm sure from wind
but water potentially i mean hey look
you tell me
it feels smooth as if it had been but i
don't know that
what i do know is that the nile once
went up to the steps basically
of the pyramids for example
what you're looking at down there so
that's the great pyramid and you see
that white structure to the right at its
base
that was the old boat house they've
since moved that boat
over to the grand egyptian museum which
is still waiting to open
but um but they found that right next to
the pyramid so the nile once went right
up to the steps here
i can't say if it was
right where i'm standing though but
let's see i can't believe i got 400
people here this is so cool all right so
let me keep walking the only thing is
that i want to go down this direction
to show you guys
but when i did that earlier that's when
i was losing my connection i think it's
because down yonder that's where cairo
is
and then if i'm between this pyramid
and the uh bedrock i think that's what
i'm going to lose connection and i don't
want to risk it again
big hug from ireland
from
uh from a brazilian guy hi there
knees over toes on youtube he will fix
your knee
guys i need
i need a cadaver graft i need a i'm
gonna have a bionic knee some for both
of them someday i got freaking messed up
knees i've had it since high school it's
called osteochondral desiccants
and the femur bone essentially is
malnourished from the blood and
deteriorates over time
um but don't feel bad for me i'm not in
any pain so life is good and i'm walking
and so i'm happy i have spent more than
a year and a half of my life on crutches
though between the five surgeries i've
had and that was it's very soul-sucking
like i'm not meant to be caged up like
that
i need to walk around and just move and
live
so it's a from that perspective that's
one reason why i want to avoid another
surgery at all costs but
at this point now i have to
but that aside let's talk about more fun
stuff here's the big group i'm getting
burnt out here i feel like all right so
i'm going to keep walking this way
and if i lose connection i lose
connection and i'll swing around so bear
with me guys because i want to show you
guys
what i'm
and i want to keep going down this way
oh my god
so bear with me if i start to lose
connection i'll swing around and go back
the other day the other way
wow
is that susan
moore i don't want to put you on the on
the i'm live
susan moore is a scientist she's a
geologist she's an expert in stones and
been doing this her whole career and
this is like your ninth trip to giza
wow i don't have to put you on the spot
but if there's anything you want to say
you can
you know i've been talking too much okay
i hear you
i'm going to pick her brain later i'm
going to buy her wine
service
again
it's because between the pyramid
and hi there
uh
go that way what a shame
it's because between here in the
in cairo being on the other side
i went down there earlier and i lost
connection too so
dang
yeah at the top of the pyramids got the
best surface around
um well dang so let me just scoot back
around the other way
let's see here
um
i might take a break on the live stream
and wait till we get over by
the third pyramid i get to show you all
the nubs
on the uh the granite casing stones of
it it's all polygonal and
um get the nub phenomena the nubs have
been seen across multiple continents
around the world
it's unclear what the nubs were for
because it's so random it's not for
lifting
and i could show you that because
there's some that have them and some
that don't it's quite bizarre
it's quite bizarre
but here's something else you guys got
to see watch this so let me show you
what i'm looking at
see all this guys but you don't realize
that these are all cut blocks that were
formed together all polygonal and
massively eroded but all this these are
all
i mean like this like you see what i'm
saying
all cut blocks
pieced together
thousands of years of erosion look at
this
what is all this about
somebody said all right sean murphy
thank you so much
oh this is unreal i don't know if you
guys can see this the way i'm seeing it
because it's
through a phone but the amount of stones
that are missing from this thing is
unreal
people have quarried this they used a
lot of the stones of the pyramids to
build mosques and other things in cairo
and this thing has just been pieced
apart for so long
again all these granite blocks just
thrown about
here's a dog
hi doggie
he's sleeping
man
let's see how many people we got in here
1400 hi everybody
wow look at this dog
you gotta be careful like i'm a big dog
lover but these dogs are very skittish
of people because people out here don't
treat them good it's very sad hi puppy
oh okay yeah i'll leave him alone he's
going to run away i don't want to pester
him
but okay going back let me show you guys
more stuff here
look at all these blocks you see what
i'm saying
heavily eroded all polygonal all piece
together at the base of the pyramid
someone here let's see someone just sent
me
lost soul connections are you going to
see the sirpian temple yes tomorrow
i can't wait i'm going to get some great
footage i won't be able to live stream
in there because it's a freaking cave
it's underground but i will certainly be
filming it
wow
again all these stones that i'm walking
on all cut pieced together
see that
polygonal
wow
you guys are funny i'm looking i'm
trying to i'm missing so many of the
comments it's hard to see especially
since it's so bright outside my screen
looks really dark but look at this look
at this
that's polygonal so just to
show you my boot
and see how this
i hope you guys can see it like i'm
seeing it
look at this
all these polygonal blocks i mean look
at this one
look at this let me show you
see what i'm saying
all throughout is that wild
and look at this one i mean look at this
look at that
and that's something
i want to keep walking but i don't want
to leave the group too far away they're
all way down there
hmm
i'd like to walk you guys down over by
the sphinx too
wow
look at this
i don't know if you guys can see but the
amount of stones are missing is unreal
someone wrote hey mom i'm on tv thanks
for the work you're doing
comp who is that i don't know
that's what do you mean confer or kim
forgive me i don't know how to pronounce
that thank you very much for the super
chat yeah
oh someone said do it bring us to the
sphinx so here's the deal that's that is
about a half mile away that way or so or
maybe not that far
but i have to leave the entire group i
really shouldn't do that i shouldn't
wander off like that because we're all
going to be accounted for
um
let's see here let me show you guys some
awesome
casing stone so look at this thing look
how freaking big this thing is let me
flip it around let me do the whole
selfie thing here
so look at this
look at that
like
let me flip this around
look at that
and again from 500 miles away look how
freaking big that is i mean god all
right let me climb up a little bit
i'm holding up
and you can see evidence where they had
in more modern times used wedges to
break
pieces of it off
wow
unbelievable
and again just showing you guys for size
comparison
i'm one step up
someone gave me a super chat that is so
awesome thank you so much magic
look at this
i mean look at this one too
this is one so this is the bedrock as
well look at this
it goes
it's all one piece that's one block
until it goes up there so i'm trying to
see if this is bedrock as well like it
is down on the far end
because it's not throughout the entire
pyramid
let's see
let me flip back around
this is fun
500 people hi everybody
if you've ever thought about going to
egypt
you got to do it
it's so magical
this place has such a great feeling to
it
the people are unbelievably friendly and
welcoming
by the way if you guys
am i back
yeah
service is going in and out around this
um
anyways like i was saying follow me on
instagram because i'm posting things
that you won't see here
and it's hilarious this awesome guy had
bought a whip in peru and he brought it
to egypt and i posted to my story just a
little bit earlier of me like cracking
this whip in front of the great pyramid
seriously hilarious
um but anyway so yeah just plug in my
stupid instagram i mean i despise
facebook and they own instagram so part
of me doesn't even want to advocate it i
despise mark zuckerberg
the guy's a tyrant
he's a censorship
fiend
and that's
it's just wrong i don't like censorship
let people say what they want to say
don't get me going guys
god i still can't get over this so again
to those of you that are just tuning in
this is a quarry that was used
for the limestone blocks of this pyramid
there's a lot of debate about ancient
casting and that they formed amount of
concrete and like i was just saying
earlier there's issues with that one of
which is there's a quarry right here you
can see where they cut the blocks out of
i mean look at it
also all the blocks are essentially
different sizes if you're using concrete
you would have like a cast you know i
mean it'd all be like the same size or
most of which would be someone andre
thank you so much you're awesome keep up
the great work jimmy thank you oh here
we go man it's going next once we get
over to
the so bear with me guys in less than an
hour i imagine we'll be over